on se replace monsieur duceppe au début
des années 90 alors il ya une ferveur et
des pendentifs
évidemment il ya la déception face à
l'échec de meech le bloc au début c'est
une coalition pourrait même dire une
coalition arc en ciel avec le vu des
conservateurs notamment lucien bouchard
des députés aussi du parti libéral
aujourd'hui ça semble impensable mais
comment tout cela s'est formé au début
avec eux jean lapierre ans gilles
rocheleau nous rejoindra en début
septembre
pierre est vaine l'année suivante donc
il y avait cinq députés conservateurs
dont lucien bouchard bien sûr et c'est
jean lapierre et lucien bouchard qui ont
surtout travaillé le texte de l'émission
l'année suivante en 91 le bloc sera
deviendra officiellement partie avec un
manifeste en 93 avec une carte forme
politique le précise touchant tous les
domaines toutes les compétences
fédérales
je pense a été très vite c'est unique
dans l'histoire que de voir des députés
de différents partis fonder un parti
souverainiste à ottawa pour défendre
essentiellement des intérêts des
québécois et des québécoises considérant
que l'instance démocratique supprime
damnation québécois c'est l'assemblée
nationale n'y avait pas de ligne de
parti à l'époque puisqu'il avait pas de
programme ça viendra 93 et c'était de
s'inspirer des grandes valeurs
économiques politiques sociales de la
société québécoise avec un préjugé
favorable pour les plus démunis
grosso modo c'est le rôle qu'on a joué
jusqu'à 93 lorsque nous sommes devenus
la surprise de tous le position
officielle officielle à ottawa
oui et certains l'oublient vous êtes le
premier député à avoir été élu sous la
bannière bhl québécois star 1990 lors
d'une partielle et c'est lucien bouchard
monsieur duceppe est allé chercher oui
c'est à dire que c'était moi je négocie
à ce moment-là l'ensemble le secteur
hôtelier c'est pour vous et
j'essaie de gilles bouchard j ai si j'ai
terminé mes négociations
on s'est rencontrés le 7 juillet et
insister beaucoup même gérald larose
motivation est remplacé aux questions
finalement j'ai terminé 9 juillet et là
où j'étais entraîneur semblait
l'investiture
ça s'est passé un rythme fou et c'était
palpitant
on a établi un programme pour le comté
en quelques jours on n'avait pas de
local au départ on les avait strictement
à rien on a fait une campagne où il ya
eu neuf 9 débat politique c'est denis
coderre et morceaux sur toutes les
bestioles 1 contre 9 des bons dans une
ancienne la sauce terre record 80 ans
vous en avez parlé ses coups de théâtre
le bloc qui rapporte 54 sièges devient
le plus officiel j'imagine que c'est une
période qui était grisant mais il y
avait quelque chose la plus bizarre hein
monsieur duceppe un parti
indépendantiste qui devenait
l'opposition officielle à ottawa
oui tout à fait mais c'est la démocratie
est aujourd'hui on se bat beaucoup se
battent tout au moins pour la
proportionnelle ou une forme de
proportionnelle certes pas la
proportionnelle intégrale on voit ce qui
se passe en israël c'est pas un exemple
à suivre mais une forme de
proportionnelle et la proportionnelle
c'est quoi finalement c'est de faire en
sorte que tous les courants politiques
présents dans une société soient
représentées dans les instances
politiques sinon ils sont ailleurs
c'est fondamentalement ça le
professionnel donc au québec même dans
des temps où la souveraineté pas à son
plus haut niveau 35 38 selon les
derniers léger léger c'est tout de même
35 38 pour ça c'est important que les
gens soient représentées dans les
instances démocratiques et rappelons
nous qu'en 89 des bus 89 qui aurait
prédit à ce moment là on sondait même
plus sa souveraineté il n'est il ya eu
une élection au québec où le pq sous
jacques parizeau fait élire son nom 27
députés qui auraient présent 89 que
l'ami de bryan ma journée principal
ministres de ce cabinet lucien bouchard
deviendrait chef l'année suivante des
partis souverainistes et dans trois ans
la position officielle personne qui
aurait pris 10 à moi j'ai toujours dit
dans l'histoire de l'humanité on voit
qu'il ya
y a pas de choses surprenantes ya que
des choses inattendues savez le mur de
berlin ce pour surprenait qu'ils soient
tombés mais pourquoi il est tombé en
novembre 89 c'est inattendu
ouais c'est la même chose avec ces
phénomènes où il ya des lignes
politiques des espoirs des enjeux des
valeurs qui sont là et qui apparaît sur
l'artiste se reviennent selon le
contexte est ce que ça vous a surpris
parce qu'on parlait justement donc de
surprises
est ce que ça vous a surpris les
défaites celle de 2011 que vous avez
subi on sait que le npd avait une vague
du npd qui sait quel regard vous avez
donc sur cette période là on a sûrement
fait des erreurs trois semaines avait on
avait vingt points d'avancé imaginer
demain mais distrait que le bloc soit
peut-être l'opposition officielle et en
trois semaines je pense que rien un
phénomène
jack layton très important très
sympathique jack et qui affrontait la
maladie et tout ça à jouer et nous on
n'a pas attaqué suffisamment le npd
l'époque c'était certainement les reins
pour démontrer les incohérences parce
que jack layton nous parlait
continuellement de la déclaration de
sherbrooke
mais ils n'ont jamais mis dans l'eau
plate forme politique parce que ça
déplaise au canada donc on a parlé au
québec mais ça on aurait dû faire sortir
ça mais ça l'est le passé c'est le passé
on voit les erreurs qui ont été faites
il faut les corriger pour l'avenir puis
accepter les défaites
j'ai toujours dis moi que quand on me
dit que le peuple a toujours raison j'ai
dit non le prépare tous les droits dont
celui de se tromper
sinon il ya plus de démocratie par ça
veut dire que le lendemain d'une
élection l'opposition rose ils le
peuvent pour choisir on peut pas
critiquer le choix du peuple
ça marche quand même des démocraties
mais tous les droits oui il faut
toujours respecter le choix du peuple et
plusieurs chef par intérim a eu des
crises également de leadership au sein
du bloc québécois
on avait l'impression qu'avec yves
françois blanchet le parti avait trouvé
un chef pour longtemps mais là on a vu
ces allégations d'harcèlement sexuel
lors des derniers jours est-ce que vous
pensez que ça lui enlève la légitimité
et à monsieur blanchet non maintenant
que vous seriez accusent-ils de
l'agression sexuelle succès anonyme de
ces progrès allez-vous cessé d'animer
l'émission un ca pas de sens envion mais
caractère de gauche
moi je pense que il faut agir comme
québec le fait actuellement avec un
comité nos partisans de quatre députés
quatre femmes qui sont en train
d'améliorer le système de justice parce
qu'il faut de l'améliorer désormais
exemple les plaignantes ont le droit à
un ou une avocate pour les représenter
et pas seulement que l'avocat de
l'accusé puis le procureur de la
couronne soit c'est important parce qu
on est 6 me des ces personnes il faut
agir comme ça sinon on entend des
dénonciations anonymes chapelle de la
pure vengeance pointe à la ligne et en
terminant seulement sur l'actualité et
me succède le bloc québécois qui
menacent d'ailleurs on le vit donc
seilhac cette annonce est de faire
tomber le gouvernement à l'automne si le
premier ministre son ministre des
finances ne démissionne pas ce que c'est
un coup de bluff
qui veut vraiment retourner en élections
pendant le parent de mille moment je
trouve très difficile de retourner en
élections d'une pandémie j'espère que ce
ne sera pas le cas le parti qui est
moins bien placés pour une élection
c'est certainement pdj qui est en grande
difficulté financière et qu'elle subit
un recul important aux dernières
élections
cela étant dit moi je serais pas surpris
que monsieur morneau démissionne et que
la chef de cabinet de monsieur trudeau
en face d'eux mêmes comme c'était le cas
gerald bac est là tous les partis pour
réduire ben il ya eu au moins un bout de
chemin de fait parce que ça pas de sens
là ça pas de sens ce qui s'est passé
même le voyage à londres 2
ou sophie goy rattraper leurs convives
n'étaient là que sa fille et madame
sinclair la merde je sais c est moi
j'aimerai savoir qu'un monsieur mono si
j'ai donné 50 milles pour payer en dons
est-ce que des reçus d'impôt pour ça
lorsqu'enfin données reçues ce que ça
veut dire que les contribuables ont aidé
à payer ses voyages ça n'a aucun sens
j'apprends saisir vous vous et je prends
l'avion geinoz lg des roms et nous
d'oublier que j'ai pas payer mes moyens
limités à demander que déjà vous trouvez
qu'un légitimité donc à demander la
démission du premier ministre est
également aussi lumineuse et finances
assurément pas avoir encore par a parlé
beaucoup cette sympathique comme député
ça veut dire comme député ça veut dire
comme mais d'un savez des fois on
n'obtient pas toujours tout au 1er
siècle si scénario que je soulevais
c'est monsieur morneau démissionner
n'obligera pas monsieur trudeau à
l'explosif
si sa chef de cabinet faisait comme
jérôme bats
moi j'ai l'impression que les partis
europe il ya un pas de fait de taux - de
reconnaissance
on va être plus vigilant à l'avenir pis
il devra surtout être plus vigilant à
l'avenir
merci beaucoup monsieur duceppe d'avoir
parlé de ses 30 ans du bloc québécois
est également aussi de l'actualité merci
bonne journée
merci bonne journée